it is a quiet somerset village now at
the center of a double murder
investigation
police confirming the young couple 33
year old jennifer and 36 year old
stephen chapel were killed inside their
family home on sunday night
specially trained officers uh providing
support to the families of both stephen
and jennifer and our thoughts continue
to be with them at this awful time
post-mortem examinations
are ongoing and i confirm that
jennifer died of multiple stab wounds
while forensic teams continue their work
at the house it's emerged the couple's
children were inside at the time of the
attack police have confirmed that the
couple's two children aged just five and
six were found upstairs asleep in their
bedroom they were taken away by police
and are now being looked after by family
members
police used drones to capture aerial
footage of the crime scene on tuesday
while drains alongside the road were
pumped and searched
meanwhile a steady stream of flowers and
tributes were laid by a community
clearly shaken i know that something
happened i don't know what but actually
at the end of the day i think it's
extremely sad what happened those poor
children that poor family
they've lost everything just before
christmas
i have a job myself and i think it's
absolutely gut wrenching
police have been given more time to
question a 34 year old man arrested on
suspicion of murder a 67 year old man
has been released under investigation
extra officers are patrolling this
village
after what they describe as a tragic and
heartbreaking incident
dan whitehead sky news in norton
fitzwarren somerset